uh speaking of great news you know what
goes well together
national dessert month and a pie sale so
rocky
is live right now at marie calendars
where they are serving
some sweet deals this season hey oh look
at that rocky what's going on out there
hey you guys okay so we're gonna start
this off and we're here with yuri at
marie callenders and you know what it's
all about here
pie and it's finally fall and we get to
celebrate national dessert month which
is october
with the fall pie sale so i'm going to
start off by testing out
what pie this is yes you brought me out
a few slices
i only have time for one but you know
i'll be here for a couple hours
yup oh pumpkin
it's pumpkin definitely pumpkin right
definitely all right i'm a dessert
you know connoisseur i guess so tell us
how you guys are
are celebrating here oh definitely us
here is a place to celebrate
with our 20 different flavors that we
have and especially right now they're on
sale
it's starting at 7.99 and you can choose
for like different flavors that we have
chocolate
banana raspberry lemon um
french apple pumpkin definitely you know
oh yeah seasonal ones
yeah definitely and i know i understand
that people can come in here and buy the
full
pies but they can also buy the crust as
well right uh yes we don't want to do it
they can do it
yeah definitely why not if you want to
just say time
you need to buy the pie right now on
their personally i prefer
personally i prefer uh you know that you
guys make them and i just buy them and i
eat them right yes um so
also of course you know there's more on
the menu here angel
yes but how do you guys celebrate fall
what is what is the
proper fall meal here at marie calendars
well definitely you know our traditional
one turkey dinner especially coming up
for the holidays
you know we got the fees that we're
going to start celebrating after paisa
right into fees for thanksgiving
uh definitely one of the best uh sellers
that we have
all right uh yeah definitely we know
we're ready for the holidays i think uh
we got plenty of things yes we need to
we need something to celebrate and this
is of course
gonna bring you and your family so much
joy so coming up in the four o'clock
we're going to do
some we're going to learn how to make
these pies okay yeah definitely can we
do that
with definitely absolutely yeah all
right i'll send it back to you guys
don't be jealous jc and mercedes
bring some back rocky we'll check back
in with you during the four o'clock
newscast it looks delicious mercedes
what is your favorite you got to go to
pie mercedes what is it oh i like in the
summer the strawberry pie marine
calendar so good how about you
pumpkin pie pumpkin pie